good afternoon everyone this is Ben
Busby I am the genomics outreach
coordinator and bioinformatics training
lead for NCBI I am joined here by Peter
Cooper who is the strategic
communications coordinator for NCBI who
are we talking about downloading human
genome sequence variants and annotations
from NCBI today I'm going to do most of
this is a live demo but I've prepared a
set of slides covering most of what I'm
going to talk about as a back up those
slides are available at this link go to
usa.gov etc as well as slideshare.net if
you go to my page on both of those
resources there are quite a few other
slides and presentations so feel free to
check them out or you can always google
for NCBI webinars if most of you are
like me you probably start your search
with Google this is what we find most
users do and one thing I might Google
for is NCBI human genome resources I can
open up an incognito tab just so I don't
get autocomplete so I'm going to go
ahead and do that and what I might
google for is NCBI human genome
resources I don't know why my
autocompletes are still showing up
incognito but that is not an issue for
today so the first leg I see is human
genome resources at NCBI we modified
this page about a year ago we've put a
whole bunch of new bells and whistles in
and what we've done recently is moved up
the download section as a page and made
it easier to use so one thing you can do
on this page you can search for human
genes and it'll send you to the NCBI
gene page you can also click on the
ideogram to access the genome data
viewer in that region but what I want to
talk about today is downloading various
sequences as well as other ncbi
resources through this symbol to use
table so if you want the latest
reference genome sequence in either
grch38
which is the
new version of the human genome about
30% of you are using that at this point
and about 70% of you are still using the
old human genome grch37 if you're
interested in the differences between
grch38 and 37 but I only encourage you
to check out the genome reference
consortium webpage you do that just by
googling genome reference consortium you
can check out the genome reference
consortium it'll tell you all kinds of
things about grch37 and 38 anyway on
this page this gives you quick direct
links to download the the reference
genome sequence so this is going to be
the fast date but it's gzipped but that
should be accessible to most of you as
well as the GF f3 file so here you can
get all of the annotations that NCBI has
for that file some of you may just want
refseq transcripts so these are just the
mRNA sequences that are transcribed from
the grch38 human genome once we were
fairly certain are transcribed you can
get all protein sequences this is a
protein fast de you can also get a VCF
per clinvar a lot of people search for
the clinvar VCF this is a very quick way
to get it as well as the VCF 4db snip I
would make one word of caution this the
DB snip VCF is rather large as you might
expect especially since in DB snip
release 1:50 we just doubled the number
of RS numbers and finally DB var which I
think is is really increasing in
significance this is a database of
structural variants and those structural
variants really have big consequences
both in other technical work with the
human genome as well as clinical
reporting consequences however some of
you may want
API access to this kind of information
for the human genome for other genomes
as many of you are probably aware we
have an API known to most people as
utils and we've made a command-line
wrapper for that aid API called edirect
still it can sometimes be a little
tricky to use to make scripts for the
command line wrapper so one thing we've
done is we've made a little cookbook on
github for scripts using the command
line wrapper so and the amazing thing to
me is that we've made this interactive
so if you have a github account you can
put in issues for things that you might
want to do with our metadata API or you
can just scroll down copy some of these
scripts and modify them so for example
if you want to not just human but any
taxonomic designation you can grab this
script and simply just modify the query
sequence and that would give you
whatever taxonomic designation you
wanted now it does say here for larger
sets of data it may fail with a large
number of arguments we find empirically
that caps out about 50,000 so searches
for more than 50,000 items probably
won't work so well in this context and
you can do lots and lots of similar
things there's something you want to do
with API metadata crossing NCBI
databases try it and if you can't figure
it out once again put an issue in the
edirect cookbook so the last thing I
want to show you today is how to
actually look at the human genome at
NCBI and for that what I would do is
scroll down to the view portion of the
page and I'm going to load up a resource
we have called the genome data viewer
and this this really shows a lot of ncbi
resources at the same time so here I can
show lots of refseq transcripts for
particular gene loci I can show snips in
clinvar DB snip obviously and then
I can also see RNA seek coverage and
that's pretty neat if I want to I can
use the tracks menu to split that out
into various tracks but one thing I
really like about this browser is I can
go ahead and search for a disease or a
gene name and it'll go ahead and load
that up
so here I've searched for a Bowie I can
see the refseq isoforms for a Bowie
right here and I can see related genes
here you can also upload your own data
or add tracks as you wish
if you want to learn more about this
type of stuff we have featured webinars
there are also fact sheets many people
find these very helpful or once again
Google for NCBI webinars again you can
directly download the latest version of
the human genome sequences fast a as
well as annotation and associated files
right here at the NCBI human genome
resources page and with that I am happy
to stop and take any questions that you
may have so somebody who has where we
could where you can find the common list
of variants reported in all ncbi
resources and i would say that if you're
looking for short variants variants
under 50 nucleotides you're going to
want to look in DB snip and in fact for
the DB snip grch38 release that's really
going to be a VCF of all of those
variants similarly if you're interested
in structural variants you're going to
want the latest DV bar release and so
and like I said both of those resources
are available right here on the human
genome resources page so there's some
specific questions I will take a look at
them and we may answer some of them
offline yeah well we'll actually put
them in the documentation for the
webinar
all right we're going to go ahead and
wrap it up thank you very much for your
time and I hope you have an excellent
rest of the day
you